podemos reescribir la expresión 2030
como 10 por dos más tres porque dice es
el máximo común divisor de 20 y 30 o lo
que es lo mismo este 10 lo podemos
distribuir con el 2 y con el 3 si
multiplicamos 10 por 2 va a dar 20 y si
multiplicamos 10 por 3 va a dar 30 y el
resultado de esta operación 20 más 30
que de 50 va a ser lo mismo que si yo
hago esto 2 más 35 y a ese 5 lo
multiplicó por 10 5 por 10 y 50
entonces aquí nos están pidiendo que
apliquemos la propiedad distributiva nos
piden que usemos este mismo método para
reescribir la expresión 90 más 27 y aquí
nos están ayudando un poco ya nos están
mostrando esta estructura 90 más 27 es
igual a 9 que multiplica a dos elementos
que se suman dentro del paréntesis qué
números multiplicados por 9 me da 90 y
me dan 27 es decir que números a
distribuirles el 9 nos dan esta misma
son buenos si multiplico 9 por 10 me va
a dar 90 y se multiplicó 9 por 19 9 por
2 18 9 por 3 27 este sería un 39 por 3
27 y 9 por 10 90
esto me daría el mismo resultado que si
yo sumo este 10 más el 3 y luego lo
multiplicó todo por 9 pero nos están
pidiendo que usemos la propiedad
distributiva es decir este 9 lo
distribuimos en el 10 y en el 3 vamos a
ver si esta es la respuesta correcta
comprobar respuestas
si es muy bien ahora hagamos otro
ejercicio la misma estructura pero ahora
nos cambian los valores nos piden que
usemos este método para reescribir la
expresión 5535 aquí ya nos están
ayudando nos ponen el 5 que va a
multiplicar a 2 números que se suman
aquí en ese paréntesis es decir este 5
lo vamos a distribuir en el número de
acá y en el número de acá de manera que
nos quede la suma 5535 igual que acá el
número x 555 bueno pues son 25 si va a
ser 11 5 por 11 55 ahora que el número x
5 menos 35 6 por 5 37 por 5 35 aquí va a
ser 7
si yo tomaste 5 y lo distribuyó aquí en
lo que está en este paréntesis me va a
dar 55 y 35 lo mismo que tengo en esta
expresión
veamos si es cierto comprobar respuesta
hagamos otro ejercicio más ok reescribe
la expresión 4 por 5 9 como la suma de
20 y otro número entero aquí ya nos dio
otra estructura de ejercicio
tenemos este número que lo vamos a
distribuir con el 5 y con el 9 5 por 4
es 20 aquí nos dice la suma de 20 y otro
número entero pues vamos a distribuir el
4 con el 99 por 4 36 entonces aquí es
bueno 4 por 5 20 más 36 36 vamos a ver
si esto es correcto ya que este 4 lo
distribuye en los números que están
dentro de este paréntesis
veamos comprobar respuesta si estuvo muy
bien bueno aquí nos regreso a los
ejercicios como los teníamos al
principio veamos bueno veamos ahora
tenemos 12 más 75
hay que factorizar el máximo común
divisor que en este caso ya nos dicen
que es 3 este 3
tenemos que factorizar lo en otros dos
números enteros para que nos dé 12 + 75
que número x 3 nos dé 12 exactamente va
a ser 4 3 por 4 12 número que
multiplicado por 3 975 25 si yo tomo 25
y lo multiplicó por 3 va a ser 75 25
comprobar respuesta en efecto y espero
que con estos ejercicios les haya
quedado mucho más claro lo que es el uso
de la propiedad distributiva con los
números enteros nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo